[Music]  what's driving you crazy at 5 55 on your  wednesday morning well how about a  heartfelt plea for pedestrians to step  up for their own  safety viewer leslie tells a scary  wake-up call story she writes in an  email every time i hear about a  pedestrian being hit by a car i wonder  it's a result of  something i experienced one night it was  dark driving south on torrey pines two  people in very dark clothing crossed the  street right in front of me  and not in a crosswalk she writes  luckily for all of us  i saw him was able to stop sometimes  stupidity  kills can you please remind people who  are out in the dark to wear some kind of  clothing that has a light color or  reflective tape well leslie thanks for  writing and sharing we can only hope  this doesn't fall on deaf ears  buckle up drive carefully and please put  down that phone  if there is something driving you crazy  you can email me traffic 8  8newsnow.com